he was coming with my lunches some
people who are just putting people
through South Africa
tell people this scale there was nobody
who wasn't was supposed to pay a man to
tell me that also he see the advantage
nobody can say whatever better to take a
family so no tell me what happened
though so you said to the man okay I'll
take this kill yeah I think the upper
reports here from those guys I gave them
their mind how much money 1080 and how
did you feel about buying a woman
sometimes I understood at that situation
me I wasn't beaten to by him I was
looking lately
I was the thing I was sure that I'm
buying I was just trying to help you
because she's homeless
mm-hmm what did it mean when you did
hand over the money
what did she have to do for you this
girl she said I really shouldn't wake
sometimes she's working and she was
banned food sometimes she spanked me to
Ampang food also that was her lap can go
on but when you paid the money for her
did that mean that she was your wife or
what was the arrangement yeah this is
she's my wife
this is my bucket chicken coming stay
with you I just came to eat some of your
baby make my life be better by my own
yeah and what happened when you got to
the house my loyalty
there was just beating as always or
sometimes the rape does solidly push us
to come outside they need something to
to sleep with us so that they they gonna
take that money to pay and how long did
that go on for how long
I think three three weeks they cuz I
kidding me I don't have one month ear
and I kill for about two months so in
those three weeks you were kept in this
one house yeah and how many times do you
think you were raped in that time
I can see every day every day it left me
it is so hard to us they tell us what to
do they used to put us many times yeah
they feel safe yeah I feel you take care
of me
he makes sure that I eat every day as
maybe it every day yeah and we keep in
try to get me some job do you feel that
you have to stay with him yeah like you
lose things but do you feel that you
have no choice but you have to stay with
him yeah I have no choice and I will
still see when I yeah I think it's the
one who can take care of me how long do
you think you will stay with him I think
we will we wouldn't sleep every day were
good a promises we promised each other
yeah and I think I can be with him one
team
how do you view it how do you view the
relationship I mean when something I'm
alright now
I can say any problem I can see any
problem here just because she's good
she's quiet she's a good kid she's not
the same she's not like them like South
African kids which I'm singing I said
she's a good kid just because and I'm
telling this when I'm saying this I
don't like it she can't understand me
and she's no nobody knows II know she's
not having any friend who can tell me
what to do as long as he stays do you
ever think that although you you say you
wanted to help her do you ever think
that maybe you're also using her yes I
know that maybe I may be using me but
sometimes I'm not forcing me to do that
sometimes each and every time I'm not
just a metaphor as forcing it to do that
we mm in acclimate
I'm not fasting you to just leap with me
but even though if I just love
the situation that I believe that me and
me and he or I can build that love